how's it going everybody it's Lauren and
today we have some big news about the
future of the MCU Marvel is already
shaking things up big-time doing four
projects a year in phase four and phase
five doing one more project a year than
they normally do however two of these
projects that will come out each year
are going to be Disney Plus shows but
these definitely aren't going to be like
any normal TV show you've ever seen and
they definitely aren't going to be like
the former Marvel TV shows after getting
the first trailer in the first look for
the Falcon in Winter Soldier series the
one division series and the Loki series
we can already tell that these are going
to be absolutely incredible and
yesterday we got some big news as Disney
had their earnings call and during this
earnings call when Bob Iger the CEO of
Disney was talking about the Marvel
Studios Disney Plus shows he mentioned
that they have seven more currently in
development seven more than the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier
Wanda vision and the Loki series now we
know five of the seven that are already
in development we have the Hawkeye
series Marvel's what-if series Moon
Knight she-hulk and Miss Marvel now that
means there are two Disney Plus shows
currently in development right now that
we do not know about so we have even
more MCU content coming our way very
very soon and we probably know what
these two series are going to be based
off of what we've heard and what the MCU
has actually shown us one of these
Disney Plus series will most likely be
the Young Avengers we know that Harley
keiner will most likely take on the
mantle of iron lad which is most likely
why they showed him at Tony Stark's
funeral and the end of Avengers endgame
and then of course we have Cassie Lang
who was all grown up now after the snap
she is set to become stature in the MCU
then of course we have a whole entire
series devoted to Miss Marvel so she'll
definitely be a part of the Young
Avengers and then of course we have
Wiccan and speed Wanda and visions twin
boys it's been officially confirmed that
they are going to be in the one division
series as we got our first footage and
our first look at them as parents so we
already have a full young Avengers team
and if you're thinking well I wanted the
young Avengers to be a movie they still
probably will be the Young Avengers
Disney Plus show will most likely just
set them up introducing each of the
characters and their abilities and then
gradually bringing them all together and
by the end of the Disney Plus show they
should be together
then be ready for that film because
Kevin Feige has already confirmed that
the characters that appear in Disney
Plus shows will appear in future movies
and of course don't forget these Disney
Plus shows are canon to the MCU
everything that happens in the shows
will affect the movies so the Young
Avengers is most likely one of them and
then of course we have the Thunderbolts
now according to insiders it's already
confirmed that the Thunderbolts are
already in development over at Marvel
Studios and if this is true which seems
very very likely they will most likely
be set up as a Disney Plus series at
first as well just like The Young
Avengers then going on to be a movie
after all it is going to take some time
to introduce each individual member of
the Thunderbolts not to mention
Thunderbolt Ross is going to have to
gather them all together these Disney
Plus shows are a great way to build up a
team and then bring them together for a
movie this is exactly what Marvel has
done in the past they have introduced
individual characters in their own
movies and then brought them together
for the Avengers and the great thing
about bringing them together in Disney
Plus shows is that it doesn't have to
take years for the group to be
established they can introduce the
Thunderbolts on a Disney Plus show and
have a movie come out not too long after
and the groundwork for the Thunderbolts
in the MCU has already been set of
course we have Thunderbolt Ross who is
going to appear in the Black Widow movie
he's going to be Red Hulk and then of
course we have Zemo who is going to be
appearing in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series and from there it's
pretty easy to get Justin Hammer from
Iron Man to ghost from ant-man and the
wasp and possibly taskmaster from Black
Widow once they are established in their
individual movies or shows they will
come together in a Disney Plus show and
then eventually a movie based off of
everything that we've heard these are
most likely the two projects that Bob
Iger was talking about that we don't
know but again he has confirmed that
there are two other Marvel Studios
Disney Plus projects currently in
development right now let me know what
you think about these news and let me
know if you'd like to see a Young
Avengers and a Thunderbolts Disney Plus
show leave your thoughts in the comments
down below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe with notifications
turned on so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or ps4
the winner gets to choose and I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof